65, the effects-driven sci-fi movie with lots
of scary dinosaurs, is officially going extinct
at the box office. Stiff competition could be one
reason why, among a whole bunch of other factors.
Starring Adam Driver and Ariana
Greenblatt, 65 is all about Mills,
Koa, and their survival on a hostile planet
populated by dinosaurs. These two are the only
ones left after their spaceship crashes, and
Mills feels honor-bound to protect the young
Koa. This means 65 is great for people
who like dinosaurs and science-fiction.
"There's something alien out there."
Unfortunately, it looks like these people
weren't motivated to go to the movie theaters,
and 65 has missed the mark in terms of box
office returns. There could be many different
reasons why 65 is going extinct, which may include
reviews, competition, and not a lot of star power.
Released on March 10, 2023, 65 has faced
significant competition from several
different movies. A movie like 65 might
already struggle to bring in audiences,
but squaring up against the likes of Scream VI
and Creed III hasn't been kind to 65, either.
The results have been quite abysmal, with 65
making only $12.3 million at the box office. For
comparison, Scream VI earned a respectable $44.5
million, the franchise's strongest debut yet.
Besides the direct competition from Scream
VI, there are many movies that are still
generating income, like Puss in Boots:
The Last Wish, Cocaine Bear, and Avatar:
The Way of Water. This means there are plenty of
options when it comes to entertainment, and it
seems like 65 didn't generate enough interest to
overpower any of the other choices at the theater.
In addition to stiff competition, the general
critical consensus around 65 has not been
favorable. Reviews have not been kind to 65, and
Rotten Tomatoes currently has the movie at a 38%
critical score. However, it seems like the general
audience views the movie in a slightly more
positive light, giving the movie a 63% positive
rating. Still, these results are hardly glowing,
and negative word of mouth can affect box
office yields. Common Sense Media wrote:
"While this sci-fi/dinosaur
movie is competently made,
it really only has one good idea, and it doesn't
do much with it. The rest is generic, familiar,
and fails to generate much suspense or emotion."
Not all critics were unkind to the movie. Empire
Magazine thought the movie was bold in creating
an original story, noting that the film moved at
a brisk pace, and the no-nonsense plot was buoyed
by the occasional Tyrannosaurus Rex. Still,
65 isn't creating a lot of positive chatter.
Another facet to consider is that 65
doesn't have a lot of star power other
than Adam Driver. Besides Driver, the
other main star is Ariana Greenblatt,
whose biggest claim to fame at this point
is appearing as Young Gamora in Avengers:
Infinity War. Driver is not without his army
of dedicated fans, but Driver isn't exactly
known as an action star. The one exception to
this is the recent Star Wars sequel trilogy.
Beyond that, however, Driver usually isn't
running and gunning. Perhaps that was the reason
why Driver decided to join the cast of 65 as it
afforded him something different. At the moment,
however, it seems as if audiences aren't
buying into this version of the actor.
Another piece of this puzzle is that 65 is an
original property, and not part of a franchise,
much like Creed III, Avatar: The Way of Water, and
Puss in Boots: The Last Wish. Considering that 65
was created for around $91 million, it appears
as if the film has quite the uphill struggle
ahead if it wishes to recoup the invested money.
Perhaps 65 will undergo a massive change of fate,
but at the moment it looks like it's under
the looming shadow of a cataclysmic asteroid.